and uh Jordan Peterson went into Rogan
looking like Huckleberry Finn well his
pants were like look like he was in a
river well he's in a he's you know he
was in a um he was in a like a
uh what was he in like a tux with a bow
tie and short pants he's like you know
it's not immediately clear to me why
climb it is climate it's not immediately
clear to me
he you know he's been through it yeah
he's been through the ringer he's been
through the ringer and he's a brilliant
guy he's a smart guy yep
and but he looks right now like he's uh
like he's in his almost his final form
which is a Batman villain like he seems
to be he looks like he just took a break
from a catering hall handing out [ __ ]
shellfish yeah he seems like a like an
angry maitre d at a Long Island Italian
restaurant screaming about climate
change oh you don't like your table I
told you it's the only table here we
don't have an innumerable amount of
space that's the problem with people
they think there's an innumerable amount
of opportunities to eat you can eat the
eggplant rollatini and you can eat it
anywhere it's not immediately clear to
me if we put you in another table that
you'd be having a better thing the thing
about Marxism and the burrito principle
is an eggplant rollatini in any society
concentrates in the hands of fewer and
fewer people well that's correct but
it's actually so correct that you have
no idea how correct it is so it's an
underestimation of the problem your
table on the corner is an
underestimation of the problem
yeah you just walk away and you go like
Rogan needs a new car like Rogan Steve
says these guys but we got we need
someone new we need who's a new
professor we need like a new
like a new professor yeah because he's
you know he's great but he's he's you
know he's done it right
so we need like a new
yeah who would it be I don't know like
what other Professor from some college
you never heard about
yeah it's got to be it's got to be from
a small small college that didn't matter
to anyone and they have to be the next
guy yes you know yes
well I'm sure there's a lot the money's
better yeah money's better online than
it is that you know uh it's got to be
like a college like a small College yeah
and if videos got to go viral of like uh
a lesbian beating him with a stick yes
like just three lesbians beating them
with a lacrosse deck yeah or just a
bunch of students burning his book yeah
burning his book and they're like
pushing his car like if you see a bunch
of them and we can organize this and
perhaps it has been yeah but you put
someone in a car and then the students
are just like you see the car going back
and forth and the the professor's like
you know just a bunch of kids with
purple hair just pouring milkshakes on
yeah as he screams and then he needs to
emerge as like the next guy yeah and
it's got to be like the name has to be
perfect yes like it's got to be like uh
the university is always like uh yeah
Greenfield yeah Greenfield College yeah
Greenfield College in Wisconsin Dr Eric
Von schlossberg please welcome Dr Eric
Von schlossberg so you're an
anthropologist but let's talk about
microbiology no it'll be a guy it'll be
a guy it'll be a gym teach can it be a
gym teacher it has to be a guy who's
who's who's who's who's who's like
degree is in exercise science
Dr Eric Von schlossberg from uh the
University of Winnipeg brutally beaten
by four field died
is now here to talk about his theory of
you know of anti-matter yeah why Galileo
was a hack
Dr Eric Von schlossberg gym teacher
University of Winnipeg let's talk black
holes yeah
yeah no they um they've really opened up
their uh their fields of Interest yeah
they really are well everybody it's the
the
like I we always thought about doing a
Sketchers funny where it's like a guy
who's like as a mentor who's a professor
and and he sits down with him he's like
I want to let you know thank you so much
for everything you've done for me and
the professors like I'm trying to get on
Logan Paul's show
you guys what do you guys you guys like
are you so are you like working on
anything and he goes yeah I'm working on
getting an impulsive
can you get me on impulsive yeah and you
go well I thought you were kind of like
weren't you working on a theory yeah
yeah I'm working on a theory of not
being broke yeah that's exactly what it
is I got a new Theory called not being
broke yes and I'm trying to get my
numbers up yeah and he said a lot of
valuable things and we like Jordan we've
had Jordan on the show
um
you know but it's just it's it's funny
because this is a new archetype of guy
to like Renegade Professor right
Renegade Professor back in the day there
were professors who were like protesting
Vietnam yes and everyone's like you
communist piece of [ __ ] but a lot of
them were like legit
protesting a war in Vietnam